little field
are the publishers
up next on book tv encore book notes
david denby sat down for an interview in
1996 to talk about great books he
returned to his alma mater columbia
university to retake a western canon
course and he recounts how the
literature covered in the class has
shaped both his personal and
professional life
david denby author of great books
what's it all about
well i went back to school i was pushing
50 and beginning to fear that i was
getting a little stale spent my whole
life professional life in the media
and getting a little depressed by how
second hand my experience seemed at the
same time my wife and i were reading
89 90 back in there the culture wars
debate and feeling that it was hollow
and and that both left and right were
too far from the works of the western
tradition themselves here we were
hearing from the left that uh the
western classics uh disempowered
everyone except white males
and from the right a sense of these
books as a kind of armed part of our
armature and kind of nationalist almost
chauvinist
like the star wars or something like
that and uh i thought well what does
this have to do with reading montan
shakespeare dante hegel can't any anyone
you want to mention virginia woolf and i
was carrying on like this and my wife
was getting increasingly bored
with my desk camping every night like
that in the living room and finally she
said look you know
put up or shut up go back to school go
back to columbia they have courses like
this
required of all students you took them
1961 was then 30 years ago go back do it
again
that's how it started what year did you
do this i did this 91-92 academic year
91-92 it took three and a half four
years to write the book get it out and
so it's been a while since i actually
read everything again where do you live
now and where did you live in the same
place on west end avenue in manhattan
we're about two miles south of columbia
down the west side not very far away
from i haven't gone very far in 35 years
so i'm a new yorker my regular gig is
new york magazine film critic and i'm in
the media up to my neck i don't mean to
say that i i'm somehow you know apart
from this thing that we do i am
certainly not and i i love journalism uh
i love appearing on television it's all
very pleasurable but it wasn't enough
uh and i was pushing 50 and beginning to
feel you know where's the rest
uh who am i what do i know
what have i inherited
what do i want to pass on to my children
those kind of uh questions what's your
wife do my wife is a novelist kathleen
shine she's published four novels and
she's working on a fifth one and she's a
great great reader and she was a kind of
provocation
because she got she reads right through
an author's work she'll read two three
hours a night i mean when she got into
trollope the marriage was almost over
because you know how many volumes of
trollop there are
and i'm a kind of scattered reader like
a lot of journalists i skim
i mean
dr johnson said that's the way to read
but i'm not so sure i think you should
read straight through if you can i skim
i read essays i read a lot of journalism
i read novels that have to be made into
movies
and i had lost my adolescent rapture
that intimacy we have with books when
you're 14 15 16 and you know you sit
there on your bed if you're drawn to
books at all
and and for hour after hour and you look
up and all this there's the
there's the afghan that grand mar nated
well there's a red thread there's a
green thread all right back to the book
another hour like that i can't do that
anymore
i bound out of my seat after 25 minutes
i mean all these little imps of
distraction coming up from my
unconscious
twirling themselves around the text
interrupting
i don't have it i don't have the
concentration anymore
and i i mourned that
and i wanted to regain it
and i also thought if i read these a
selection of books like this they're
very very powerful works
many radical works in the sense of
pulling at the roots of things i thought
i will come into confrontation with
myself in some way that i need
that was that was the impulse max and
tommy max and tommy my sons 13 and and 9
and also
poised on the edge of this culture and
i've written since finishing this book
i've written a piece for the new yorker
about
what are we doing to our kids i mean
there's so much
pop culture not that i didn't watch a
lot of television i did but there's so
much more of it
so many different ways of selling
products are we turning our kids
into consumers you know before they even
have a chance to develop their souls are
they consumers rather than citizens
uh there's so many ways that they are
sold so many screens surrounding them
individually none of these things seem
to do any damage and you could make a
case that it's all rather stimulating
and everything and of course i write
about movies which is my
regular trade but it does upset me
when you originally went to columbia
what years were you there and what'd you
study 61 to 65.
i was an english major at a great
english department and then i went to
journalism school also at columbia so i
i did that route and it's interesting
how different the students are first of
all they were all
males in 1961 and mostly white
and now it's 50
acro across the gender line 50 50 and
about 30
minorities
i would say
uh the classes are more interesting and
more stimulating because of the
multi-ethnic mix i think it's an
improvement
i think they are not
readers however the way we were we're
not talking about iq here
very smart kids
but i don't have the sense of
intellectual obsessions
uh in the early 60s columbia students in
particular maybe all undergraduates and
schools like this had kind of cranky
obsessions they were interested in
i don't know existentialism or dashall
hammett and raymond chandler or martin
buber and paul tillock or something like
bebop jabs i don't know you know name
your own
uh i don't get unless i'm missing it i
don't get that sense anymore that they
have those intellectual obsessions that
uh that we had and that they are
habitual readers on the other hand i
think they're a lot nicer than we were
they i know i didn't pursue them into
their dormitories and their fraternity
houses and i have no idea the way they
talk there but in class i would say
because it's multi-ethnic they are very
polite and very eager not to tread on
once each other's toes now the problem
with that is that a certain kind of
blandness
creeps into conversations conversations
stop short of any kind of cultural or
sociological generalization at all
they hate the kind of trash talk they
hear on bed am radio and that it's the
last way they want to sound so they go
to the other extreme of blanding
themselves out that's that's the best
downside of it how did you go about
doing this well i i didn't uh formally
enroll or anything like that i i went
and saw the dean
and i
explained my project to her and then she
said fine just ask permission whenever
you enter
a class now there are no lectures there
are two courses one is a literature
course that starts with homer and
it goes right up to virginia woolf used
to be dostoevsky my day then for a while
it was joyce the last choice
now virginia woolf interesting shift in
taste right there
fine with me
and the other is a social theory course
that begins with plato's republic and
goes through hobbs lock kant hegel russo
marx darwin so on
right up to the present that's all
taught in sections that's the whole
point no lectures
make them think on their feet play them
off against one another
seminar time teach them
what a discourse is how to frame an
argument not indoctrinate them in any
particular idea at all not at all but
just what they are you know what a
framing an argument might be so i would
uh go seek out the teacher in advance
and explain
you had a teacher that taught you 30
years before i did yes i ran into him on
the first day and i was sitting in the
literature humanities office and he
walked in and pretended to remember me
and he may have remembered me this is
edward taylor he's extraordinary man i
remember pretending to remember
something i said on a paper 30 years
earlier i i don't know and
i said oh you're teaching this he said
come on that was that never left his
room
uh was there for nine months
and uh this was the literature
humanities course which he teaches as if
the whole thing were a giant poem as if
he had the whole thing in his head he's
been doing it for 30 years is he any
different uh well i didn't take this
course from him i had taken a course in
17th century poetry he's tends to be
very mysterious and say odd things and
put the students off bounce and then
draw them in
slowly uh no he's just just better
and then another teacher was a young man
named james shapiro who was a completely
different style he would do a kind of
mock naive routine at the beginning of
each week as we took up a new text in
the literature course he would ask the
students whether they liked it
do you like homer i mean do you like you
know i was sort of stunned by this the
first few times he did it
um and then as their responses came out
and and they would were encouraged to be
very candid
um and they would say occasionally
callow or naive things he would then
take those responses turn them
inside out open them up play the
students off against one another
embarrass them tease them
like that
and it isn't easy and i know it isn't
easy what he does because he asked me to
try it
uh he i kept raising my hand uh i
thought i was you know we're told in
journalism school
sit there with your steno notebook and
shut up right don't make yourself part
of the story that was my original
intention
i found it impossible i was
too excited uh brimming over
and so i'm not in taylor's class but in
shapiro's class and then the social
theory was going on me
may i speak
so shapiro uh
sensing
my need or perhaps feeling a little bit
crowded uh i said would you like to
teach and i now know he was setting me
up because he has written an article
describing what it was like having me in
the classroom
and i said sure and uh it was jane
austen
two weeks down the road and i thought
well
that should be relatively easy
because we've been reading epic poems
homer and we've been reading sophocles
and euripides and we've been reading
philosophical dialogues plato and montan
rather difficult essays
uh and i thought well and and
shakespeare well now last we've gotten
to the to the novel the one the you know
the form of the bourgeois era the thing
that all students know
and this is before the jane austen
movies
they've been three right in the last
year and i thought but still i thought
jan austin everyone loves jane austen so
shapiro did his thing he said did you
guys like it and it was very
apparent that
the girls liked it the men didn't then
he turned the thing over to me
and i i was angry i was furious at the
men i thought they had to you know they
had to love jane austen or else they'd
never grow up uh they had to realize how
important elizabeth bennett the heroine
of pride and prejudice was because she's
a kind of student
and janos it's it's it's a love story
it's basic romantic comedy plot that
people have been stealing from for 200
years but it is about knowledge and
perception how do we read one another's
characters how do we read letters how do
we read each other how do we read
ourselves pride and prejudice
and she's a kind of ideal student and
they're of course students too so i
bullied them and i lectured them and
shapiro was getting
sort of tense and nervous and drumming
his fingers and glaring at me and after
about 40 minutes he called me into the
hallway and he said uh you know what you
were doing
i said i think i was
oversteering the ship
we agreed this was a nice way to put it
and
what he was too kind to say was that i
was doing the mistake making the mistake
that all
beginning teachers make running to the
answer out of fear of losing control
and he said look
it's a seminar that's the whole point
you can't just give it to them it's not
and then they'll just feed it back to
you on on the exam no
bring it out of them then they'll
possess it
pull it out of them and they'll possess
it it'll be theirs forever
so
that it's not easy
you had another teacher too and i had
ander stephenson who is my nominal
academic leftist uh a swede from the
socialist tradition but uh delightfully
counter cliche a wonderful teacher and
turns out he utterly believes
that every society has the right to
inculcate its leading values in its
young students
and he uh what spoke the talk the the
contemporary academic jargon and yet was
uh very gentle with the students um
never indoctrinating anyone uh the
notion that uh you know radicals are
taking over the university and turning
out copies i think is absurd um i don't
only a very bad teacher we do would do
something like that of course there were
it was clear what his values were and
what his politics were but there was
immense freedom of discourse and he was
very respectful say the religious
students and conservative students all
he wanted them to understand was that
that their attitudes were not just given
to them they weren't in in nature that
there was something that had been
constructed
this is big
left academic
formulation at the construction of
social attitudes right
by by capitalism by the market by
society by a whole series of other
things what they actually believed was
not his interest to argue them out of it
he just wanted to frame an argument and
we did we had some
powerful conversations there did you go
to class all the time i went to class i
mean did you ever skip a class or i
don't think i skipped any classes i
didn't
always stay up in the reading however
it was hard because i kept doing my job
uh as a filmmaker
as as film critic of new york magazine
and i have two children and interesting
wife
and a normally
busy middle class new york life no
busier than anyone else's but busy
enough
you say that uh
i mean i read you in the book saying
that you remember the sds out in
stanford i was in 1969.
through tomatoes i threw a tomato at
ronald reagan at sacrament in sacramento
uh and and some sort of uh we went we
stanford sds's went out to the valley
with uh with our cal university of
california brothers to protest a two
slight tuition increase at this
magnificent uh state university then i
saw later that you call yourself at one
point a neoconservative well i have no i
would not call myself i always say i'm a
clinton liberal um but i i that whole
chapter which is that's the affair of
the tomato uh which is buried in the
rousseau chapter uh is is very rueful
look back at my uh abortive non-career
as a sixties uh counterculture radical i
mean i i was a middle class
intellectual or whatever i am from the
start and all of that
was opposed but a few of the
conservative reviewers have a book have
seized on that one
passage as if i were still throwing
tomatoes at ronald reagan and that's not
the case
uh now it's a highly ironic look
backwards the moment i think in the book
that
that got my attention more than any
other was
your mother
yeah have you heard that before i mean
that is this yeah that chapter yeah the
the king lair and your mother
yeah why the comparison well you
certainly read these books differently
when you're 47 48 than when you're 18
19. i mean if lionel and great columbia
teacher and critic used to say the book
reads you turn it around
it finds you
not terribly interesting at 18. perhaps
it finds you more interesting at
35 and more interesting yet at 50.
and when i read king lear at 48 with
this time around my mother had died just
a couple of years prior to the beginning
of this project and she was this great
businesswoman in new york
and very loving person but uh she she
got real tough after my difficult for me
after my father died and she quit her
business and became lear-like in her
demand
for more love than i could possibly give
her at any one moment
and uh i didn't always handle that
situation well and so i had gone through
this and this is part of what the play
is about that lear begins by demanding a
there's a kind of show trial of
affection from his three daughters he's
an old man not failing in any way as far
as we can see he's intellectually
certainly all there tremendous drive and
energy but he's tired he's 80. he wants
to give up the kingship and he poses
this terrible trial of affection among
his three daughters which
you know of you loves me the most not a
question we should ever ask our children
and two of them lie and betray him and
the one who truly loves him cordelia
keeps herself silent
so as i was reading the play i kept
thinking
about my mother and myself and i you
know and i thought well is this going to
be vulgar to bring the greatest play in
the english language
by comment consent into relation
with my own troubles with my mother and
i thought it just
there's no law that says you can't do
this you know it just depends how you do
it
and and that's what that chapter is
about then that yoking of those two and
going back and forth
between my personal experience and the
classroom uh and the play itself and the
way professor taylor taught it now i
noticed the students had some trouble
with that play because they
still are still subject to their parents
power they haven't gone through yet that
thing we all have to go through where we
have to be the ones to take care you
know and to make arrangements
and we don't want it necessarily but the
power passes to us in some cases
and it's very difficult no human being
is is prepared i think for that
transformation in your relationship to
your parents you uh describe in some
detail how your mother died uh was that
yeah tough thing to write about
uh
yes and my my father too they both died
in new york very suddenly and i
discovered my mother's body when i came
back from a trip uh
and uh it was
it was hard yeah the whole the whole
thing was hard but uh reading the play
was so powerful actually it was a kind
of catharsis uh
for me personally it is i mean it's also
an astounding work of poetry uh let's
not make this thing out in into just a
therapeutic exercise
i think it's probably is shakespeare's
most powerful play
the star the family falls apart and the
whole universe cracks i mean there's a
kind of bending and cracking of the
whole the whole state the whole universe
the animals begin attacking
the human masters everything
turns upside down it's quite remarkable
but it begins in this banal thing which
of you loves me the most the demand for
love from you know from an aging parent
so
that was that was one of the most
powerful
experiences of the whole year
and there were others and i don't mean
to imply
that the 30 years difference between me
and the students always lay to my
advantage
it didn't necessarily um
we got to earlier in the year to the
book of job great biblical poem
and um
job loses everything here's this middle
class equivalent of a modern middle
class many fabulously wealthy powerful
guy with
with
sheep and goats and
it all goes and i thought of myself
not that i'm
wealthy but i'm thought of the drive to
succeed
and to build your family as a kind of
fortress which is very much kind of
modern american thing
and how i was like him and i was angry
at the students at first because they
made mild what seemed to me mildly pious
remarks about this
story being just about spiritual testing
and they had no sense of what job had
lost
and i did and i was having awful
fantasies of the roof falling in on on
my family and that sort of thing
and then the second class i listened a
little more closely and their remarks
got a lot stronger and i was i was
embarrassed because i thought no i'm i'm
the one getting this thing wrong
uh the last thing that this
biblical poem should be is is an
inducement to to any kind of self-pity
which is i think what i was feeling said
that
you were surprised at how much you liked
jesus
yes jesus
not that i had not read the the gospels
before i had read them three or four
times but
i don't know why but it struck me
it struck me this time uh in a different
way and i use the word witty which may
seem blasphemous but but not if you
if you mean by wit this
extraordinary intellectual comprehension
and also the ability to reverse the
situation
and pull the rug out from under his
opponents rhetorically morally
spiritually every other way
uh and i sort of fell in love uh with
with jesus in the gospels and i had to
clear away all the dreck you know and i
said so think of all the movies i've
seen and and all of the sort of
sentimental representations of jesus in
our culture how incredibly tough he is
how incredibly strong he is and smart
as well as
you know spiritually magnificent so that
was that was a revelation uh
how religious are you i'm not religious
i'm a secular reader and and i was
fascinated by the by the religious
students
uh i i wound up admiring them much more
than i thought i was going to
a lot of them
were very strong and first of all the
other students were fascinated by them
because they believed something you know
so few of today's students do they have
a kind of
derisive
attitude towards everything i think that
i think there's some kind of ironic
habits of mine built into growing up as
a consumer as i said
everything is for use and then discarded
and nothing really matters for instance
a lot of them had trouble with greek
tragedies where people die
because of what they learn about
themselves or they die for a principle
or or the aeneid or a queen dido her
lover ania sleeves leaves her for a
mighty reason to go off and found rome
right and after he dallies in carthage
for a while with queen she kills herself
students couldn't understand that a lot
of
trouble with that
dying for principle
and i'm glad that they are forced to
read these things because they should
know there's a grander life
than contemporary american life that
there has been and so when there were
students who believed something
had literalist conception of the bible
the other students
were both respectful and a little
skeptical and we try to you know argue
and it was very interesting you say that
the names of the teachers are their real
names but the names of the students
that's right why did you choose not to
well i thought it was not fair to drag
someone at a tender
age 18 a vulnerable point into my
spiritual adventure
they might be embarrassed by something
they said 10 years from now and it
wasn't fair
uh i thought to actually name them but i
wrote down about 25 names
as i went through this and i thought it
might be interesting just to go through
the names that you used and just tell us
a little bit about these students if you
can you remember if i can remember well
it's been a while let's start with noah
martz noah martz is actually a good
friend
and he's a graduate student now back at
columbia uh uh he's in history not his
name no that is not his name i'll say
his name because he's a published writer
his name is adam schatz and he's
published articles and uh he is a
budding uh
historian uh and writer i would say
and he was
one of my heroes among the students
because he was extraordinarily well read
there was the exception to the rule from
a small town in massachusetts had read
his way through
the uh his high school library by the
time he was 16 or 17. you know and that
is is a rarity at any time
but particularly now yeah what about
manuel alone he is a blind uh musician
of puerto rican descent
uh he lives in new york the times has
subsequently written the long
uh piece about him and uh did they give
his real name uh they did which i'm i
will i'll try to remember in a second um
and uh he uh
studied by reading the books uh either
in braille or by having them read into a
scanner scanner would re would then
speak the the words in kind of bland
centurion tones i did go visit him
in his room and uh and he had theories
about everything and drove the rest of
students crazy but at times but he was
remarkably articulate in fact
uh noah and manuel the two students that
we've just named pseudonymously were
often at odds
with one another sally
throwing a blank on that model
oh she's red hair yes she she was a
conservative student from a small coal
town or a former coal town in
pennsylvania and it was interesting
and took a very hard line about
everything it was interesting to watch
her transformation she was a freshman
through the year
as i think literature actually opened
her up and not softened her but gave her
a more complex
view
of life as the year went on um
how did you by the way here's leora
cohen
she was a jewish student uh who was who
was uh fighting some of the christian
texts she orthodox during the year yes
um it's fascinating
how did you invent these names i just
found equivalents to the actual names
rob lillian though
he is uh uh
has
actually been very successful as a
graduate student in california and has
named a little a comet or something
already now these people are now 23.
uh when i caught them they were in
either 18 or 19. so and i obviously
latched on to some
bright ones because uh just among this
little group here and i don't know what
happened to the woman i called sally
you've named three or three or four
people have distinguished themselves
already at a very um at a very early age
so god if anyone looked at me as an
undergraduate so they would not have
thought i would have amounted to
anything because i doubt i said much did
you ever sit in the classroom and say
this this that kid is just not bright at
all or you have to be bright to get into
this school in the first place you have
to be pretty bright some are very quiet
uh and turn out to be great uh exam
performers but just don't much feel like
talking and yeah this is true in any
class they're going to be as i said i
don't think i talked very much
in any class there's going to be about a
third who don't say much
and occasionally an instructor will try
to pull them out and if you can't
there's no point in
you know but what you don't want is
valuable unimaginative students
dominating a class and i saw you know
instructors cut off students
occasionally
this program will be eight years old in
april and you're the two
391st book notes guest
and we thought it might be interesting
uh as i was reading this thing i saw the
names of all the people that you read oh
yes we plugged in the computer and went
back over all the transcripts and you
know they have word
word recognition on that so we counted
oh my god we counted you know you know
most of the books on here are political
in some way or another
but we counted the number of references
to all the people that you write about
and we're going to roll this on the
screen right now if you look up on the
screen you'll see it
and you can see that the number one
there is john locke lock 74. how
interesting well we'll just go all the
way through we'll come back
we'll come back to lock and then mark's
the bible plato 28 shakespeare 24.
lennon 21 aristotle homer malcolm x
these are madam smith virginia woolf
acidity
is six we're getting we're heading down
towards the bottom here cicero well
that's understandable
voltaire
calvin
and the these names are matching now
that's a surprise yeah hannah arendt
go to hobbs montan
well we'll get montana in there again
let's go back to lock john locke yeah
he's number one far and away more than
how interesting
well locke a
17th century british philosopher uh
wrote a treatise of government second
treatise of government the one we read a
small
but incredibly densely woven pamphlet uh
about that
the relationships of property what
constitutes a society he creates this
philosophical fiction of a state of
nature how did we get out of it
and so on and a lot of it a lot of our
notions of uh the what holds us together
property and mutual respect for one
another's right to exist
and also our notion of rights that uh
very important for jefferson and the
other founding fathers that you know
locke
provided a kind of de facto uh
justification for revolution it was the
time of the glorious revolution in
england that he wrote this you said
actually that he was locke was thomas
jefferson's master yes so people have
debated this some people feel that
that's not true but uh
i think that's the general a consensual
notion that
jefferson took a lot in the declaration
of independence from locke and you know
i was i would try to use these people as
well as learn from them but also try to
understand my own experience and with
locke and hobbes who worried how we get
from a state of nature and to
civilization and what could propel us
backwards
i thought about something that happened
to me which was being mugged on the way
to work
it had happened 15 years earlier
something like that 1981
and i was held up by two young men at
the top of the steps coming out of the
subway at 42nd street and park avenue in
new york
uh and i i played that experience
through these texts because we seem to
be at a time in this society when things
are
not falling apart but where we are at
odds with each other and we wonder if is
there a generally agreed upon notion of
truth
uh is there an is there an agreed upon
notion of what rationality is and what
its uses are
and i i kept doing that i i had
forgotten all that experience uh and it
kept coming back
you in that chapter you put hobbs and
lock in the same chapter but in all
these book notes we've only had hobbs
mentioned once
well hobbes is sort of a primal
conservative in the sense that he came
comes before locke and his notion was
that if uh
we're not uh impressed by fear that we
will be at each other's throats
that man is by nature acquisitive and
greedy and aggressive and ambitious and
will take away his neighbor's property
if he can possibly get away with it
and therefore when we climb out of a
state of nature we make this is again
this philosophical fiction we make a
kind of agreement
to give up our freedom uh in return for
which we get protection and i don't
think uh hobbes cared terribly whether
with oliver cromwell or charles ii or
whoever it was running england as long
as it was run
i is not not a libertarian i believed in
the fear keeps us honest you james
madison came in second but you only
mentioned him on one page uh well
because our our section did not read the
federalist papers but uh there were
other sections that did and i think by
the way that uh since these the idea of
these courses is what has come from
europe to the united states and
influenced the civilization that it
would be an excellent idea for all
sections
to read the federalist papers i would
also
even consider in the literature course
perhaps in the last week doing a week on
emerson and whitman
the other there are no american not many
american texts here the third one was
marx and in our list and um yeah tell
the story about the the color
lester kolakowski
polish historian of marxism and uh a
kind of liberal in the in the 50s that
is an anti-stalinist in poland uh who
wanted uh
marxism with a human face you know in
socialism by the human face and was
defeated and left and went to oxford and
then to the university of california
and has written the big three volume uh
history of marxism came to colombia just
as we were reading marx within a few
weeks and it was it was after the the
fall of
uh the berlin wall and the ending of
soviet communism and he was incredibly
derisive towards marx to my astonishment
uh
and
just ridiculed him and so i it it made
me think is there a reason to continue
to read this these texts by marx
do they have the same relevance that
they would have 20 years ago and the
conclusion i came to
was uh just from the selections that we
read
the early so-called humanist marks prior
to the communist manifesto around 1844
when he was very young is extremely
worth reading
and has certain insights into
the nature of living and this kind of a
civilization that we need to hear we
need to know
you said that when he was speaking that
some of the faculty got up and walked
out yeah because uh it's on any in any
major american university they're going
to be a lot of people who sort of cut
their teeth on marks and who can still
consider him absolutely central whether
communism has fallen or not and they
were offended i think by kolokovsky's
blanket dismissal and i mean the
prophetic side of marx is all drivel but
the
side that's analyzing the nature
of capitalism and early industrial
capitalism still very much worth reading
uh for students and i think some of them
liked it
so you say no one is going to be
indoctrinated believe me
are there
this is kind of a thread you write about
all three about professors is there uh
still across the country in schools is
that the last place where they still
believe in marxism i don't know how many
of them believe in marxism it's just the
notion that this has been
extraordinarily powerful and it's still
interesting and that it's it's a text
worth reading
uh that there are uh
that it's a it's a tool of analysis
let's put it that way uh with that that
you can't
do without um so in the same chapter you
have john stewart mill
absolutely and uh mill
is uh i sort of defined our values of
free speech and free freedom of conduct
so long as it doesn't impinge on anyone
else's liberty and is central to
anglo-american
um civilization it's a little bit
depressing to read mills like a great
pamphlet on liberty it's very
tough-minded
uh and much more complex i think than
he's given credit for but it's
depressing because
in victorian england the churches were
very powerful and there was a very
strong sense of shame and he just took
for granted
that that's why he was able to say we
should there should not be any break on
conduct as long as it doesn't hurt
anyone else uh he was able to say that
because of the power of shame and and
when you read mill you think god all of
that has vanished when did you have time
to read
well it was rough i had to uh
i would read late at night i would read
while kids were taking a bath i would
read on the subway or try to which was
ridiculous you can't read plato on the
subway
i i
got a little room at columbia under the
rooftop of hamilton hall i would read
before going home for dinner
and i was constantly
falling
falling behind like any student
i would catch up in big
you know bursts
more than once in here you would say i
don't understand a word of what that guy
just said right and i tried to be candid
about the difficulties of this because
some of these books are very difficult
and the german philosophers kant and
hagel whom i had not read much of before
were very difficult and i had to change
my habits really
uh to in order to read hegel uh and i
discovered reading him aloud
was actually very helpful because
hegel's uh introduction to the
philosophy of history the book that we
read this is a hundred pages only and is
known as easy hegel i would say easy for
whom uh this is these are lecture notes
and they
the book was put together by and many
other hegelian texts were put together
after he died
uh by colleagues and students and they
have a kind of incantatory repetitive
but but uh incantatory eloquence
that is much more apparent and even the
meanings i think more apparent if
you read it aloud so i would declaim it
you cannot be embarrassed you've got to
learn to read aloud
of course any poetry sounds better read
aloud homer was never meant to be read
on the page of course it was chanted
homer it's not even clear that homer
wrote anything down it's not clear
entirely clear to us whether or not he
had written language at his disposal
he taught other people as enormous if
there was a historical home these
enormous poems and then they went they
they they were chanted rapsods of early
early rappers
entertained people for the three nights
say chanting the iliad or the odyssey
anyway hegel also
uh
sounded better aloud and i began to
understand him at last by reading it
declaiming against the late night
traffic on west end avenue
that was a lot of fun it was like
climbing a mountain
and
falling back and falling back and then
climbing up and falling back
it was it was difficult but
i felt every muscle straining and when i
finally got to the point i thought i
understand stood
uh
a good bit of the introduction of the
philosophy of history i i was very very
happy that was one of my high points i
mean i don't i don't mean to make this
sound like some uh endurance test this
whole year it was great
i i was i was thrilled i was i felt like
i was pressing up against the frame of
my life every day
and i think that's what i needed uh at
that point who was new and i you say
that uh there are some 130 authors
overall that they come in and out of
this great books
in the literature course at one time or
another in different combinations yeah
they i think in any in a year they're
like 25 texts but i mean all the ones
that you've read the new ones that got
you excited that you had boccaccio i'd
never read boccaccio we were at rabelais
there was a there was a plaza
is a great uh humanist that comes after
dante in florence
and and did everything uh he wrote early
kind of psychological novels he was a
scholar of dante
uh and he also during the he wrote this
extraordinary collection of stories that
the camera on about young
aristocratic men and women who uh
leave the city of florence during the
black plague and entertain themselves up
in the hills
in a very decorous way they tell dirty
stories now their their conduct is
impeccable
personal conduct there's a frame around
the stories and they're not being prigs
they're keeping certain possibilities
alive while this awful plague is going
is going on now not all the stories are
erotic but many of them are and i had
never read them before except perhaps in
playboy i had read
stealing the magazine from under a
counselor's bed when i was maybe 13
back there in the early middle 50s and
you know after looking at jane mansfield
maybe for an hour i i think i barely
remember occasionally
uh looking at
some boccaccio in playboy because they
had this something called ribbled tails
i don't know if you remember ripple
tales they would take some classic
erotic tale
and i went back and looked at playboy
and i see that the editing sort of
killed the fluency of the style
so i have no idea what i got out of it i
probably just went back to jane
mansfield but uh that was the only time
i had read boccaccia before and and it
was how great a storyteller he was how
complex these little stories are and how
frankly liberating they are in today's
terms because boccaccio had a secret
that he let you you sense immediately
uh that women were interested in sex you
weren't supposed to say this perhaps or
they weren't supposed to admit it women
initiate many of the intrigues
um in uh in these tales that that lead
to earthly paradise
and that was a surprise
and some of the young men in the class
uh in different classes i i traveled
around because i was curious how people
would respond were a little bit uh
huffy about about boccaccio
found that i mean i heard words like
debauchery and
things that you would not expect a 19
year old to complain of and i think this
the bocach has been in trouble you know
most through most of
the 600 years since he he has been
banned and prescribed and so on and on
and for adultery uh for the man but i
wonder if it isn't the sexual activity
of women if that isn't the real reason
so i found this
in our sudden dreary sexual climate of
today where there's so much suspicion
and anguish back and forth across the
gender line i found this here's a guy
really an old-fashioned hedonist who
doesn't think that sex is power he
thinks it's pleasure that was that was a
that was a an eye-opener you wrote in
the machiavelli chapter in america a
grown man or woman
reading at home during the day is not a
person to be taken seriously that's
because i was chased from room to room
not intentionally but simply uh you know
the normal activity of the household
chased me from the study to the bedroom
to the from the bedroom to the kitchen
from the kitchen to the nannies room
where i would sit on a bed
with underwear sort of hanging down on
my shoulders and try to read saint
augustine so
yes i don't i don't think
it's hard to find a place to read in the
city of new york an incredible
modern metropolis unless you go out into
the park
uh you really can't find anywhere where
there isn't music playing
uh some of the the big corporate atriums
or do you say atria i don't know but
those vast
glass enclosed spaces you'll be sitting
there and it'll be nice and then you
know the
sheen of muzak will come through the
plastic trees and
there goes or if you go into a coffee
shop and you know take that really
strong boiled coffee at the bottom of
the pot you know then you're going to
relock at last and then someone in the
you know runs the coffee shop will turn
on uh
either it's an easy listening station or
a talk radio program it's just so hard
to find any place
to read in this culture
how did you
go about
writing a book that you thought a
general population would read about all
these
people well
i i've sort of said already i think the
point was to make it
as accessible as possible after all i'm
not a scholar i'm not a literary critic
i'm a movie reviewer i can read a little
bit i can write a little bit and i
thought i have some talents for
exposition and i have some feeling for
pleasure you can't be a movie critic
if you don't in some way believe in
pleasure even in shallow immediate
pleasures
uh you can't be a movie critic without
being a hypocrite that is if you don't
believe in those things because that's
what movies are giving us it's not that
they can't go deeper they can't and some
do
but i thought if i can connect the kind
of excitement you get from a movie to
the deeper pleasures you get from
literature if there's some connection
between immediacy
and and reflection
then i i can attract i can take someone
by the hand and pull them into the
labyrinth of one of these texts now
these i have to admit are are not are
rudimentary readings
because there's no space you know to
really develop an elaborate
interpretation but i was very eager to
capture the experience of reading and
the varieties of reading in this late
20th century
period when our reading has become
problematic in some ways what's been the
reaction
well there's there's been a very wide
reaction that there's some you know
incredibly flattering reviews from a
very nice people joyce carol oates and
sir franker mode and
and the the conservatives
on the other hand have have been on my
tail because even though the book is
quite conservative and it's in its
belief in the canon and the necessity of
reading these books
uh i i
don't
always approve of the ways people like
william bennett lynn cheney and roger
kimball and so on other people
talk about literature which
strikes me as philistine and uh
um i think that uh i think it should be
said that
the conservatives pointing out that
something was wrong in the way the lit
that the universities were were
preserving or failing to preserve
the the literature and philosophy of the
past when they said that in 1980 and 81
they they did a service there's no doubt
about it
um
but
i don't
i think now it's enough culture war
there are too many people who are not
interested in culture they're interested
in culture war and uh if you don't agree
with them on every point and this is
where i got clobbered then you're
dismissed altogether
uh and i i i find that stuff on
illuminating i try to listen to both
sides i try to be as even-handed as
possible i interview the left-wing
teachers and give them a long platform i
try to give the conservative case i make
what i think is the conservative case in
some ways
for reading uh literature so uh i i'm
very
bored by partisanship
uh in in in culture i don't think it's
proper and then there's been another
attack by helen vendler of harvard
um on the grounds that this is simply
not the way to to talk about literature
and uh and she and she's applying the
kind of standards that would be
appropriate for a graduate seminar
in poetry say to what i'm doing which is
to it's just to discover how freshmen
who have never read seriously before are
reading so i think she's misapplying a
kind of very narrow and orthodox
university way of studying literature to
what i'm talking about which is a whole
spectrum of reading
i'm not approving of everything that's
said or every every every way that these
books are taught here i'm a reporter
and i
am reporting on the life in front of me
how many of these books do you think
you'll sell
well i don't know there are about 70 000
in print at this point and i'm told it's
selling steadily and
it's not a best seller but it's selling
steadily all over the country
and there have been four
foreign sales so it's i mean it has
touched the nerve i think it's been
widely written about when you travel
what are they what do you often hear
from people when they've read it and
they how do we do this they say well the
two kinds of things that's one thing how
do we do it
and uh in other words
we can't go back to columbia we know the
time or any any school and of course
there are universities that have all
over that have
wonderful programs
where you can read classics like this
but suppose you can't do that
and the answer is you form a group there
are already thousands of reading groups
in the country mainly women who are
keeping fiction alive
men think when they get together they
have to talk about politics or sex or
sports you know this stuff is a lot more
powerful than what they're talking about
but the way to do it mixed company would
be best a group of like-minded friends
that is curious people
who want to know what's in this stuff or
either never read them or haven't read
read them in 30 years and then someone
has to play
teacher
because you can't read a fifteen
thousand six hundred and ninety-three
line paul
the iliad
without some expectation of class
discussion i think at the end of it i
don't think you would um many of us
would i don't think i would have so that
there has to be that group and someone
has to
work up some background
all right we're doing nietzsche next
week the genealogy of morals it's an
amazing book uh
not difficult to understand line by line
but very difficult emotionally to deal
with because it does nothing less
and challenge the whole basis of
judeo-christian civilization
and so things went wrong
thousands of years ago when we left the
pagan and barbarian barbarian ethos
we've been infected by pity this is
very very difficult to deal with someone
has to work up some background
who is nietzsche where does his book
stand in his canon
what were the other books related to
it's not hard i mean you know it's fun
actually
you can just use the introduction
perhaps to the translated volume
do a little work and then just get the
conversation rolling just to get people
to talk to one another and then it will
take off
because you already find each other
interesting and you're probably already
having conversations
not in a group but on one one-on-one
basis that's how you do it how many um
great books
courses are there around the country i
don't know i decided not to
to file a report of this you know the
status of western classics let other
people do that i just wanted to report
on this one
experience certainly this stuff has
receded a great deal uh from i mean
colombia and chicago are still doing it
and there are other places where it's an
elective
stanford has its version which caused
the big uh brouhaha a few years ago
because it mixed in eastern texts as
well as all western texts and those who
oppose it feel that it's now a
smorgasbord which doesn't doesn't stand
for much of anything so there are
varieties of courses
but certainly they are not
as popular as they were 30 40 years ago
and i think most of the arguments
against them are hui
the notion that for instance that you're
going to lose your identity if you're
african-american or asian-american by
reading a collection of selection of
western classics
it doesn't work that way people aren't
assaulted in their identity by reading a
great work of art i mean art doesn't
oppress people art is what we need more
of
in this culture if anything it
strengthens your identity and i spoke to
a number of quite a lot of
african-american students and went
through meetings in which and which
sometimes protest against these courses
was registered
um and well you can't generalize but
some would say look you'd have to be
made of stone not to be
turned around really really knocked over
by one or two of these books in each
semester in each course
and when those who those who opposed
them and said that it was part of a
white oppressive eurocentric tradition
when you got to the reasons that for
their problems with the west and what
and it turns out what they were
complaining of what was
the failures injustice
racism and slavery of failures of equal
rights
and so on well
those notions
are western notions that each of us has
a soul either spiritual or secular and a
self worth developing and saving that we
believe in representative democracy
representation those are all western
notions in other words they criticized
the courses in terms that they got from
the courses or or from the culture and
they required courses by the way they
are required so i thought well
that's fine the books have done their
work then in other words they're going
to take the stuff mix it with their own
identity remake it reuse it use it any
way they want but it's not going to wipe
them out i mean that that's just a
melodrama i know how you're working out
actually
you know the notes and all that in the
class and did all the students there
know you were doing this oh yeah no i
would
introduce myself and uh make a little
speech
and they would look at me oddly because
there was daddy and then who was this
other person you know sort of rogue
uncle or who was he uh
but uh after a while they accepted me
and i take notes i took very very
careful notes as much as i i tried
bringing in a tape recorder a few times
and it it's not for me i my training is
to take notes because you edit as you go
and uh then you then you you wind up
throwing out most of it because there's
no way uh you know of using uh
everything that happens in an hour and
50 minute class
these accounts of classroom discussions
are highly edited
uh and i've cr you know created a kind
of narrative when i do go into the class
i kind of make a drama of ideas and
bring out students and clashes between
different students and different points
of view and
my own point of view and teacher's point
of view and that is a drama dramatic
structure that i've slightly imposed i
mean i didn't make anything up but i may
have rearranged the
slightly write i mean over the you'd say
how
order
it took four years to write it i i tried
to feed as much of the notes into the
computer as it happened as i had time
for but um i
wasn't able to because i was writing
movie reviews all you know week after
week
so
uh i then waited till the year was over
and sat down and wrote a very long
chapter on homer which wound up in the
new yorker which was a great help having
having people respond to the
work and getting some uh response
feedback right at the beginning of the
project and it just took another three
years to write and rewrite it's quite
long and i left out a lot of people and
i feel very bad about it i didn't do any
of the scientific texts
i didn't i didn't do descartes discourse
on method which is so important and i
didn't i ducked galileo and
darwin who i love whom i love and i
i feel badly i didn't do freud because
it was a can of worms i decided not to
open so i ducked a few things and a few
times i just didn't really respond
i don't think you're at this faust
part one really works in translation any
translation that i read to me it sounded
seemed bombastic and crass and w.h.r and
has said that girtha was the master of
every form of german poetry from the
highest to barracks
bar room
uh
so i believe him but it just didn't work
for me and there were other cases where
i reported failures uh of and when we
read dante's inferno
not having any italian
reading in translation
we i think were reduced in one of the
classes to a rather doctrinal reading of
the poem rather than a poetic reading
and there was this very striking moment
when the teacher asked an italian
student just to read the first can
beginning of the first canto of the
inferno
and she read and she didn't read with
any great emphasis but it was so
beautiful i thought oh god this is corny
this is like something in a movie it
can't be happening but
i think we all felt uh kind of grief at
that moment because we knew
that you know we were not able to link
sound and meaning and we were missing we
were missing so much of it any of the
students or the teachers that
read this book and fit and
feed it back to you what they thought
uh well
columbia's reaction's been generally
pleasant a few of the younger teachers
uh
have been a little bit upset because
they don't like to have their picture
taken
uh and in fact i would say many of us
you know can be self-conscious in a
situation
like that uh if you know you're very
it's a tender time for them uh they did
agree and i don't think they they regret
it but there are aspects of the picture
that
may perhaps make them a little bit
uncomfortable i'm sure you know every
reporter also has had this
experience when you know you write down
exactly what someone says and put it in
the paper and they say i never said that
you've got it your notes you've got it
on the tape recorder people are
sometimes
upset by what they sound like when they
think oh how will kali yex respond to
that how will colleague why respond to
that but i hope it's useful for teachers
that different ways of teaching these
books i hope there's one thing you said
what did people say to me when i went
around the country
high school teachers
came to readings often
and said things like i can't get them to
read
they will read john grisham
and they will read terry mcmillan
right popular black author but that's it
uh what do i do
and uh i i was i would say well
if that's all they'll read let them read
that but then try to work back in other
words if it's grisham and they're
interested in
in detection and the law and so on try
to work back to poe and well and from
there maybe to dickens bleak house
that's a big jump from john grisham but
at least you can establish a level of
interest and work back and if it's terry
mcmillan
go back to zora neale hurston great
black writer or
if they're interested in romance go back
to colette and from there to flo bear so
that's
another thing many people said one of
the teachers told you not to come back
uh yes a young woman teacher
i blew that one uh i i asked one
question
in the class and
she called me
and said look this is not going to work
students don't like it
apparently the students had complained
afterwards and i bit my lip in fury
because of course she was right and it
was a certainly tactical error to say
anything on the first day but uh
i was sort of i was bubbling over kind
of bullies i couldn't uh i i should have
controlled myself but i didn't others
didn't mind
so
she yes she threw me out next book
i don't know someone suggested that i
write a book about asian classics which
i think would be impossible because
it would not be an act of repossession
but uh i would i
would like to read asian classics let's
put it that way
and see if i can
learn something about another culture
now
this is the book it's called great books
by david denby who writes film credit
criticism for new york magazine and as a
contributing editor to the new yorker
thank you thank you very much it's great
fun
the redesigned booknotes website now
features over 800 notable non